essien adventskalender ja was sollen wir
dazu sagen es sind nagellacke 24 stück
ich weiß auch nicht warum war warum ich
den bestellt hat aber irgendwie hat es
mich dieses jahr in den fingern gejuckt
natürlich habe ich mir meine nägel dafür
wunderschön machen lassen dass ich sie
jetzt mit dem nagellack versauen kann
quatsch mit atomfreien nahen gekriegt es
wieder runter und dann habe ich wieder
meine
bibel heißt es und bevor das hier wieder
alles wirkt wie eine große kooperation
dieses videos nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses videos nicht gesponsert ich
stehe in keinem kontakt mit essig oder
mit sonst wem hier ich bin nur allein
ich bin schon den ganzen abend extrem
traurig weil ich taylor swift neue
version von portugal gehört habe und das
video dazu gesehen habe und einfach mich
fühle aber ich liebe es kommen hätte ich
bin in einer sehr glücklichen beziehung
aber ja der song löst irgendwas in mir
aus ok yaez adventskalender ich habe ihn
bei zalando gekauft und er hat 50 euro
gekostet
falls sie jetzt keine nagellack experten
sind es ist so eine marke da würde ich
schon sagen high end nagellack also da
kostet so eine flasche 89 euro und das
ist für nagellack er schon ganz schön
viel ich habe in meiner jugend meistens
nagellack von essens gehabt und der
kostet glaube ich so 150 2 euro ja aber
da muss ich auch sagen ich hatte sehr
viele farben also ich hatte zu einem
zeitpunkt so viele nagellacke und das
ist dann auch in die geldverschwendung
auch wenn die nagellacke so günstig
waren heutzutage mache ich mir ganz
gerne gel nägel und wenn ich keine
gehabt dann eigentlich nicht ich hab
zwei finger ich hab'
ich habe zehn finger das heißt ich kann
zehn tage lang ausprobieren aber wir
machen jetzt erst mal auf ich bin
gespannt was da so für farben drin sind
was ist denn gerade in der nagellack
welt mut deren macht man gerade bei sc
nagellack jetzt hier einen guten deal
mit dem 50 euro finden wir es gemeinsam
heraus
willkommen in der sc weihnachtswelt der
verpackung sieht gut aus ich weiß nicht
was das ist eine art kaufkraft dann kann
man ihn so tragen praktisch all dies
ist ein wiederverwendbarer ist hier
wieder verwendbar ja praktisch und auf
der rückseite können wir das auch normal
öffnen
ok erst die zweite hälfte wir haben
natürlich nummer eins oder sehr gut
wieder verwenden türchen nummer 1 nummer
1 oder 1 1 also erstmal
sagt man dass full size fullsize preise
schreiben wir natürlich auch auch um zu
gucken was wir hier wirklich dafür
bekommen was für ein mega hammer rabatt
machen wir mit diesem kalender acht euro
ja das hat mir von der farbe ich bin
jetzt kein so großer fels mir persönlich
zu kühlen türchen nummer
kommt man jetzt haben wir eine kleinere
fläche ein klient kann der wasserstand
strong start
er zeige auch nicht erklärte also nicht
einen nagellack base cool ich finde das
sollte irgendwie beschriftet sein
irgendeine erklärung müsste dazu gepackt
sein
13,5 mm
[Musik]
also ein drittel haben wir die hälfte 4
unterlag bräunig nummer drei was
befindet sich ein türchen meinte trifft
findet sich auch ein schmaler nagellack
aber diesmal eine farbe wir haben hier
einen wunderbaren roten ich rede jetzt
einfach die ganzen bei qvc und dieser
wunderbare roten
misses rage ist einfach eine ganz
fantastische
winterliche farbe 13 60 für drei kleine
flaschen 362 durch 34 50
euro dann kommt man wie kriegen nicht
nur nagellack grotesken clarify nähe
polish rimowa auf dem steht nicht
anzutun frei deswegen kann ich den jetzt
nicht benutzten wegen meinen gel nägeln
125 milliliter auf 1025 das heißt ein
fünftel
61 holen wir sind schon bei der nummer
fünf so jetzt ist dann wirklich geile
farbe grün nicht mehr drauf machen
möchtest
special flasche dies so in sich hinein
gedreht das ist wieder eine
59 euro kostet
die ist aber sehr sehr zeitig das der
perfekte nagellack wenn man nicht
wirklich nagellack tragen möchte aber
die nägel so ein bisschen glanz haben
sollen sind bisschen gepflegt aussehen
sollen sieht man jetzt auf diesen finger
natürlich nicht so gut aber die farbe
die behalte ich mir du wirklich wirklich
ein guter scheiße meine fingernägel kaka
aussah oder ganz bewusst kaufen heute
haben wir nikolaus und der nikolaus hat
uns was mitgebracht hatten wir hier
steht das drauf standest du mit dem
nicht drauf gestand bei dem drauf top
coat und so eine geschlossene flasche
sehr stylisch ich weiß auch das sind ja
ganz normale nagellack flaschen aber es
macht das irgendwie so dass das so
hochwertig wirkt und dann ist das so ein
es ina lack und nicht normal
platin und gold finden
also bei flakon nie kostet 12 euro 12
euro 12 euro
der kostet halt einmal 12 und einmal 50
also 12 euro ja krass türchen nummer 7 h
das sieht aus wie eine unicorn fabel war
schaut euch diesen einhorn
ist ganz toll dass ich viel gehen die
trocknen schnell man doch nicht so oft
rüber gehen das grundsätzliche problem
mit nagellack ist ja dass der einfach
nie so trocknet wie man möchte ich kann
ich denn hier so verkackt haben so ein
bisschen stücke ich sie das geradeaus
und schlimme problems in der trockenen
so schnell dass wenn ich zu schnell
drüber male das dann so klumpp men
stehen jetzt besser geworden jetzt sage
ich stimme zu der farbe wichtigere frage
was sagt ihr zu der farbe es hat so ein
flieger und frolow effekt also dieser
natürliche tun gefällt mir mega gut und
der ist irgendwie ja das ok als nächstes
türchen nummer 8 und jetzt habe ich
langsam lackierte fingernägel und es
wird schwerer das aufzumachen kyu so ein
richtiges bonbonrosa ist leider
überhaupt nicht mein fall deswegen werde
ich nicht auftragen aber sieht sehr
hübsch aus in der nummer 9 meine freunde
wird jetzt eine farbe drin sein die wird
mich so was von umgehauen und diese
farbe ist
ja ja doch irgendwie ist diese phase für
mich vorbei so krage lag weniger findet
wenn jetzt irgendwie eure lieblings habe
hier das ok also vier euro mal wieder
chinchilla heißt die farbe also ich
finde die farbe schön das ist aber eine
wunderbare wandfarbe nummer zwei ist
auch ein top coat weiß ich nicht wir
haben wir hier wieder ein klagelied wie
heißt good to go nahm überlack
nummer 11
das ist mal ein
das ist ein ping ping ping ping ping
ping mutzke ich will die farbe unbedingt
auftragen aber ich weiß dass wir immer
im schrank liegen bleiben wird ich
fragte mich auf was haltet ihr von
diesem pink das ist wunderschön nummer
auch wieder wirklich von der kategorie
wandfarbe gebiet baby kipping die wege
länger als die shorts bikini
wunderschöne wandfarbe auf den nägeln
würde ich glaube ich auch traurig drein
aic aller vor wenn das nochmal krieg 3
ist zehn milliliter das testen wir jetzt
mal wie quick drei die wirklich sind
leben euro 15 und jetzt
kommt der härtetest die farbe ist schön
gar nichts gesagt
so schnell auftragen ist
trocknet schnell
vergesst was ich gesagt habe war schön
richtig tolle wandfarbe meinem finger
oder wow jetzt schon trocken nicht noch
mal drücken und damit gehen wir auf die
nächste seite
die hälfte es schon rum ich sollte öfter
nagellack adventskalender auspacken das
geht hier wirklich rucki zucki tisch
nummer 13 in typische nummer 13 befindet
sich
classic roter nagellack tatsächlich
besitze ich die farbe und sie ist
wunderschön und sehr praktisch forever
yummy heißt sie also jetzt mal so im
vergleich hier haben wir so ein haar ich
würde schon sagen wieso ein pastell iges
bordeauxrot irgendwie und das ist halt
so ein richtig knalliges rot rot was
befindet sich
aprikosen öl für die nagelhaut sehr
wichtig eine schöne gepflegte nagelhaut
macht auch sehr viel aus das kostest du
immer wieder
wie trägt man es auf man macht es sich
hier an den rand vom nagel drauf also
einmal hier 15
ich will mir nicht so seien hier ist
diese farbe drin und die farbe hatten
wir ein bisschen vorher drin die
haarfarbe heißt sugar daddy und die
farbe heißt heim maintain es kann auch
sein dass ich noch mal von der leg kraft
anders sind
also das ist schon sehr sehr ähnlich
türchen nummer 17
die farbtrends könnte schon besser sein
das ist jetzt mal wieder ein rot nicht
zu vergessen wird unseren anderen runde
ja sehr großer unterschied ist natürlich
sehr wichtig jetzt auch so ein kirchroth
es ist ein kirsch das sind
unterschiedliche rottöne aber
richtiger naja muss das nummer 18
not chips ahead das ist schon wieder ein
klarer nagellack lassen hier los auch
nagel überlegt jetzt haben wir zwei top
kurz eine base code also ja ich will ja
nicht undankbar sein aber irgendwie es
ist ja die haben so viele verschiedene
farben also es ist ja eigentlich nicht
so schwer türchen 19 und in der 19 er
wirkt nicht
dort habe ich gerade habe ich versteh
ich gerade irgendetwas nicht
natürlich lebt
ja
dran
war viel los ich verstehe nicht ich
verstehe es einfach nicht nummer
u16 haben übersprungen sorry oder schaut
einer jetzt hier guckt mal schwarz das
ist natürlich eine ganz neue farbe
schwarz das es ist toll verrückt wir
sind schon in den 20 jahren angekommen
ja es ist ein essay kalender also
passiert eine
bei letztlich
wisst ihr was ich möchte ich morgens auf
und weiß nicht recht und
in farbe nicht cool kinder hier nun mal
21 bin sehr gespannt was für eine farbe
wirkung ja man denkt auf den ersten
blick noch mal schwarz aber nein es ist
so ein auto nicht schlecht sind sehr
sehr dunkles blau im blau ist ja doch
ganz schön groß aber jetzt nicht
irgendwie meine nagellack
after school boy blazer ich habe gerne
ahnung was das bedeutet türchen nummer
nein es ist heisst roger haben ein
unterschied manchmal fühlt man sich
einfach wie ein klares rot manchmal
möchte man ein dunkles brot manchmal ein
rot mit einem pastell unter tun manchmal
ein mit seinem kirchen tier hier nummer
23 ein tag vor heiligabend
ja ja das ist meine wandfarbe so ist
gewarnt also ich habe nichts gegen diese
farbe die ist ganz toll das ist meine
wandfarbe die wand auf dich grabsch aue
hat exakt diese farbe deswegen tipptopp
toll und so nude töne sind ja auch
gerade sehr modern hier und da kommen
wir auch schon zu unserem 24 türchen was
steckt drin wir sind alle ganz aufgeregt
das wollen wir doch sehen ein toller
goldener glitzernder nagellack perfekt
für den trage ich mir aber sofort auf
nein das ist wirklich das herz habe ich
freue mich darüber
war guckt mal wissen wie schnell aus
meinem
basic
nägeln weihnachts werden der quick 3 ist
auch schon trocken guck mal wie trocken
was ich machen kann
der korrektur von es ist einfach nur job
das ist krass ich reibe da richtig
drüber und bei dem h bei dem für sie das
anders an seit wann geht das mit
nagellack auch eine tolle kombination
sehr schön blau und gold
hier seht ihr mal
das goldene wieder zu glitzert der
goldenen nagellack gefällt mir geht's
gut besonders in kombination mit denen
gemacht ich stelle mal die farben bis
hinauf zum glück eher die zweite kamera
da kann man das mal so ein bisschen zäh
gezählt
das sind unsere farben die sind ja
eigentlich ganz gut ich mache mal dass
hier wieder weg wir sind ja eigentlich
ganz gut die farben ich hätte mir
irgendwie für die weihnachtszeit
schönere weihnachts farben gedacht ich
habe das gefühl gerade bei diesen farben
also das sind 5 die so ähnlich sind die
rottöne okay da sind so müssen
unterschiedliche nuancen aber hier ist
vollkommen in ordnung ist dann halt
unterschiedliche denkst dann haben wir
hier noch 3 und das goldene oder sind
das gerade so die berner farben bei sw
und ich verstehe das noch nicht schreibt
es mir sehr gerne in die kommentare was
ihr zur farbauswahl haltet
nichtsdestotrotz rechnen wir jetzt
einmal den preis zusammen denn ich
glaube der wird sich lohnen ich komme
mit meiner wahrscheinlich verrechneten
rechnung bei 123 25 raus sagen wir ich
habe mich und 20 euro verschätzt 100
euro wenn man ein großes event ist dann
ist das eine wunderbare gelegenheit
viele farben zu bekommen für einen
kleineren thaler aber gerade bei
nagellack frage ich mich ob es nicht
schlauer wäre sich dann für 50 euro
wirklich die farben zu holen die man
gerne trägt in der fullsize größe und
dann hat man sie wahrscheinlich auch für
fünf jahre also es ist cool mehrere
farben zu haben aber es ist immer die
frage ob man es dann wirklich braucht
jetzt habe ich mal aufgeteilt in farben
die ich auch wirklich tragen
würde und farben
die bei mir wahrscheinlich nur oben
stehen werden die trage ich die wirken
rumstehen aber wenn ihr jetzt natürlich
jemanden kennt der irgendwie total bock
auf nagellack hat aber voll wenige
farben und wären mehr hätte dann ist das
natürlich eine tolle möglichkeit einfach
mehr für den preis zu bekommen ich lese
hier in diesem fall so teils teils man
spart aber man bekommt halt auch viele
farben die einen wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so passen und bei nagellack ist
man glaube ich schon piggy also ich hab
so ein paar farben die ich super gerne
trage und ein paar wirklichkeit gar
nicht tragen aber keine sorge dafür habe
ich euch verlosen
aber wenn man sich das alles hier so im
gesamten anschaut 50 euro ist das ein
gut die ehe man bekommt halt viel mehr
raus und ich hoffe euch jetzt gefallen
so wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
hier ist meine tolle wandfarbe auf dem
fingernagel sieht super aus klasse des
daran tschüss